we are going to win a game of fall guys
without jumping
we don't win a game without jumping we
all have to
fill our shoes with peanut butter and
walk around walmart not my shoes
why would we do that who's making these
rules all right ready up let's do this
all right let's go
we can dive though diving is okay just
no jumping oh i'm a big fan of this one
big fan of this one i am yeah i have a
feeling we can get through this one
without jumping oh i'm in the front
all right boys remember no jumpsy
dumpsters
i don't want peanut butter
are you guys so far ahead of me noobs
noobs don't get hit by the first
oh oh i just used skill oh no
what there we go i'm insane first okay
no yo i'm so kidding
oh dinosaur what a cut
no all right there we go you're bad
jimmy
nope ah come on you're my how all right
taylor are you stuck here with me jimmy
you're back i got up i gotta go
i might qualify top five without jumping
carl how are you so good
what why qualified let's go please make
it guys
good no one cares i'm in dead last
yeah baby
[Applause]
no yeah
chandler did it jimmy's bad whoa jimmy
made it through the middle oh you gotta
just dive
done
[Music]
i like to put it on the record i enjoy
having peanut butter in my shoes well we
don't well we don't so we're going to
keep fighting
let me shot call for this okay i got you
i will
be defense gonna win without jumping
no jumping i'll be rumored we gotta get
blues get blues get blues here we go
i dived it i got it there we go keep it
in the corner we only have one ball
yes baby yes baby we are going to lose
we
have one no we're not we're not going to
lose get blues out
get blues out we're trying 13 seconds
get that yellow oh my gosh guys this is
so intense we got a score
oh we gotta score literally eddie go go
go
we got it yeah no it was right at the
end
no it crossed right at the end hey chris
you're all so bad you're bad jimmy
all right ready up come on let's try
this again
from the top hip bird all right no
peanut butter in the shoes
let's go chris let's go oh it's
it's actually better diving it's better
diving nope i can confirm it's not
you guys screwed me let's go i always
hate my friends and christmas
out here you screwed me yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i'll talk about it later oh
hey hey hey
hey i'm walking here yes sir let's go
i'm behind top five
top five hey hey chris i thought we were
trolling here i'm scared i'm scared
come on carl yeah we all qualified
boys boys boys boys boys boys
that one game mode didn't require a
single jump at all
what's gate crash we're we're screwed we
might be screwed we can dive over the
gates you have to dive over the gates
we're good we're good you can just dive
over
you gotta pimp it yeah just prime it
oh we're in the front row let's go let's
go let's go to the right
take it back now y'all one hop this time
yes i'm ready i get so nervous when i'm
about to
oh get up i'm in the front i'm in the
front oh i'm right i see you chris
oh my goodness oh my goodness i might
make it i might make it
please oh you can't you literally can
yes you can yes you can you cannot
oh yeah you can what are you going on
about oh
not if your name's chris apparently oh
no goodbye
no please yes i made it i made it
no no no no no yes no no
i'm on the finish chris look look chris
look i know look no i
i was standing on the finish line we're
not getting socks with peanut butter in
them please
all right guys so listen we gotta get a
cycle of games
all right that doesn't require jumping
we just gotta get lucky this is the
perfect one yeah one in the front
whoa i'm in the back whoa whoa okay at
the beginning you're not supposed to
jump at all anyway
okay just rag doll i might be first i
might finish first
okay carl quit flexing oh yes i might
finish second
ah i fell downward i'm right behind you
guys
i'm right behind you guys i made it i
made it i made it come on
come on come on come on boys get the
balls out yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes he goes
jumping full squad don't need no no
honestly i'm starting to think jumping
just holds you back and fall guys
i'm not thinking that i'm not all right
here we go let's go all right
next round let's do this i'm just going
to run down the middle oh well that
didn't work okay okay i'm doing i'm
doing decent i'm doing not bad i'm
going to be honest i'm not doing hair
this one doesn't move i'm doing pretty
good oh my gosh
it does yeah the outside ones suck
oh you freaking nerd all right here we
go
attempting to jump attempting the jump i
made it
i didn't get anywhere close i did not
get anywhere
no i did it i did it
i did it qualified i'm literally jump
diving at the last minute and i just
fall straight did only carl qualify
yeah carl is the only one left oh
whoopsy daisy uh oh
it's so hard just show up
okay thank god yes okay okay okay we're
back in the long blue
yes what every day of the week
every day of the week girl go get the
rings man
you lost my life i don't want to wear
shoes with peanut butter
gentlemen we are doing one more game and
if no one wins it
we have to go to walmart with peanut
butter shoes i just want to win guys i
really
don't want to get peanut butter up in my
toast hey doordash
okay okay okay that's a good one if you
saw the tweet you know
yeah look for the door that's like an
inch higher it's the
left far left far left right right last
door on the right right right
can you dive through though nope yeah
you have to it's not the last on the
right
no for the very end for the very last
one you idiot no i thought you were
saying the last door on
the right oh what if the glizzy blocked
me
yeah i saw that i was doing so well
until the glizzy blocked me
yep it was the right one oh they're all
going to land on top of me
yeah hey i'm walking here come on come
on please please please please yeah
baby yeah baby first let's go let's go
whoa i got kind of close we all made it
this is the last game we all made it
though so i'm very confident that we are
going to win
okay hoarders carl let us down last time
no
i do let me see if i can pull it out
guys chill we're not we're not yellow
team
we got this yeah go go
go go go go go go we need at least two
of us to stay deep please guys
all right we got three balls right now
we're good we do not need white blues
all right we're good we're gonna talk
about everybody play defense no help out
oh got it got it got it we're good we're
good we got three i'm the only one
playing deep down
back keep them back i'm literally
defending by myself i'm here what do you
mean
you were so good we are incredible
we lost one it's hard to defend when you
can't jump dude all the balls are on our
side
guys come on they're stealing just keep
them in
we got it we got it we got it emo emoji
emo
uh i'm an emote in real life look at
that oh
can we all agree thank god yellow team
lost all my homies hate you see all
those yellow guys
they should just left when it started oh
hey don't worry jimmy you don't have to
jump in this one yeah remember to
don't jump i don't understand why would
it why would it why would you not
jump do we need to dive on the first or
just fall i'd vote
watch out for the log okay we all died
we all died we all died no
so you have to land and walk go oh yes
i'm in first i'm in first i finish first
flex on them oh let's go yeah baby
i'm making it yeah qualified
oh jimmy i would have made it if
there wasn't a banana we did it coral
high five
the bananas only came for me okay okay
okay we literally can
okay we literally can do this oh yeah
chris i see you
all right we're just eating chris just
go for it i fell
no oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh oh no i made it i made it
yes yes okay i didn't make it but we got
two of us let's go
oh no oh no this could be my first dub
chandler just drop straight to the
bottom and get it
get it all cleared out all right i got
you i'll knock everyone out i have to do
it for chris so the other people will
lose because chris can last
longer than me all right i'm going sweat
mode boys
ugh it's so hard not being able to jump
chris oh my gosh it's just it's okay
it's
okay
i just i just keep on getting stuck it's
so hard without jumping don't go to the
bottom bro it's all i'm saying
you're fine chris chris you're so fine
oh wow look how fine you are
oh chris is fine get that guy out
pineapple out work on getting pineapple
out oh no find out where you're dropping
no this okay it's okay i'm gonna get
right here oh you cut me off don't cut
me off it's okay
i'm not cutting you off i'm not gonna i
died i died oh oh no i didn't mean to
there's no way i could have done
anything i couldn't jump at the end or
there's only two other people chris oh
god chris
i'm terrified no
yes wait i won i won i
won yeah i dove at the end
if you're watching this video hit the
subscribe button and we'll see you later
see ya